a science article came out last week
about monkeys okay scientists found this
is true that monkeys with smaller
testicles are the loudest to make up for
their shortcomings when attracting
females now I bring this up because man
I feel bad for those monkeys
[Laughter]
that's that's our cameraman Don what are
you talking about Don now everybody
knows the loud ones have tiny balls
thanks that's true Don yeah hate to be
that mokey huh
yeah okay hey done Don you're you're
interrupting the show okay
so just take it take it down that's
right what I was gonna say is [ __ ] stars
is hey watch where you move that cable I
gotta move my cameraman done done please
keep it down we're trying to do a show
here okay
sorry cohdon we won't have it again
right as I was saying shouldn't
scientists be more focused on things
though oh uh keys yeah what's the status
of my custom order underwear yeah the
ones with the wide waistband and the
super small pouch no no I don't want any
slacks can't just taking it yeah nice it
tight on the Raisinets
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we'll take a break we'll be right back
with cake wasn't that a great clip
subscribe to my youtube channel for an
endless supply of me
[Laughter]